yo wassup everybody prestige man Luigi
back inside of the witcher 3 with a
little bit more relaxed video than a
normally do you guys might remember a
video that i put out on some other
people for that where you go to white
orchard you kill these towels you
meditate and you repeat this step as
much as you want for infinite kal me and
gal hides it's a good way of making a
little bit of money and some food early
on in the game now there's a patch that
came out today actually a CDR project
read the developers of which 23 have
implemented a system to discourage the
practice of killing cows this system is
called the define defense force
initiative and you'll see if you do this
like about three or four times you'll
activate the defense force initiative
which is what you see on the screen
which is a giant level 27 short if you
play through a good amount of game and
you've seen the chore chores are like
fiends but they're smaller except for
this tour this short is the size of a
theme and you can see that like if
you're if you're early in the game this
tort will be like you won't even see his
level because you have to be you have to
be you have to basically be in the game
or be really far have explored a lot of
stuff to get to the level where you can
see this guy's level and then be be able
to fight him like I've be in the game
and I've been exploring a lot on I'm a
higher level than him however my gears a
little bit lower because I've been doing
gear for love I've been doing lower gear
to make more of a challenge but this
this guy is this guy's big and tough and
this is a pretty good way in my opinion
to uh discourage the killing of bovine
since in the patch notes all the patch
notes say are implemented the bova
implemented the bovine defence force
initiative or something along the words
it implemented and that the patch notes
is basically just the name of the
initiative and it that's this is what it
does it spawns a giant chore you guys
might be thinking oh it's not a giant or
what happened
you kill that short you get some good XP
um uh no this chore I I am a little bit
ahead of this tour in levels he gives me
like one XP per kill he might give
someone else more XP however he's really
he's out he's it not really yeah yeah
he's pretty hard to fight he's a tough
fight and once you kill him another one
is gonna spawn the defense force
initiative is infinite shorts I've
killed three or four of these and you
don't even need a be by the cows once
you start this they will keep spawning
until you leave the area I I tried
running away from one and then he
started killing um townspeople and a
guard stepped up so I'm like oh I'll
help you out guard and I killed him and
I was like like 100 yards away you see
there's the second one I was like a hund
and his body's I just wants to go to be
the second one I was like a hundred
yards away when I killed like the third
short and then just another torch spawn
in the same spot to defend cows so moral
of the story is be nice to the cows
unless you what actually I don't know if
you want to fight some shorts then kill
the cows but yeah so yeah guys I hope
you enjoyed this little funny thing that
CD our project red has put in the game I
found it pretty hilarious most of my
videos on the witcher 3 are more along
line tips and tricks is what's kinda
tips and tricks or guides i guess of how
to spawn how to infinitely spawn short
level 27 shorts but i hope you guys
enjoyed and if you do want more which 3
cons and go check out my channel there's
a lot of stuff like I've put up a lot of
which are three stuff since that's the
aim of them playing all the time now and
it's been making a lot of content about
it alright guys see you all later peace
up